He was the wells most wanted
international terrorist,
the Svengali like leader
at the helm of a violence,
political movements that brought havoc
and destruction the world over his names
of the world. It became instantly
familiar. A summer Ben Ladin,
we will recognize his image, a long
drawn face, the scraggly beard,
the Todd and yeah, discovering the man
behind the image that's never been easy,
causing him to be referred to as a
fact checkers. Nice map. Only now,
six years after his death,
are we able to piece together a complete
profile of the life and death of the
man at the forefront of a violence,
political movements that
significantly impacted our worlds.
And this week's biographics, we discover
the truth about a summer bin Ladin
that's all in the bin.
Ladin was born into a wealthy
industrialist family in the city of radar.
In 1957 his father,
Mohammed bin Laden,
was a builder and contractor who during
his lifetime had 11 wives and at least
52 children.
His mother was a petite Syrian women.
Muhammad was an ambitious businessmen
who had brought his family from Yemen to
Saudi Arabia in the hopes
of both advancing his own
professional opportunities
and providing opportunities for his
son's things while they went well and the
elder bin.
Ladin built important social relationships
and forged enduring bonds with
notable members of Saudi society,
including members of the house of Saudi.
Saudi Arabia is ruling family Mohammed's
bills the bend laws in construction
corporation into one of the largest and
most profitable construction businesses
in the Middle East.
As he became more successful,
Mohammed further strengthened his
bond with the Saudi royal family.
He used his money and influence Steve
Bolster the image of the House of south in
risen.
King Faisal decreed that all the nations
construction contracts would be awarded
to the bin. Ladin Corporation.
Mom had been lodged and well,
he died in a plane crash in 1967 the 10
year old a Sama was told at the time by
king five sal that today I have lost my
right hand, the construction corporation.
It was then taken over by a summer's
older brothers back in mid 1990s it was
worth an extraordinary
$36 billion the summer.
He was then Greens to enter the family
business after successfully completing
high school with he further his education
at King Abdulaziz University that he
studied economics and management
with an eye to a future in business.
He also learns the behind the scenes
dynamics of the family enterprise.
Unlike a summer,
most of his brothers chose to attend
western universities where they were not
constricted by Islamic tradition.
This was particularly true with the Samas
half-brother Saleem known for his good
looks and discharge.
Psyllium was educated in London and flew
his own private plane in the late 1970s
Isama now in his mid teens began
to enjoy the excesses of wealth.
He would regularly make the trip to Beirut
Lebanon to take in the excitement of
the city is fast paced nightlife.
He spent hours frequenting nightclubs
in casinos and often drank more than he
should have. He also began enjoying
the company of beautiful young women
around 1975 however,
Osama bin Laden had a spiritual rebirth
causing him to return to Islam with a
third and devotion that altered his
goals and lifestyle drastically it again
when he decided to help with
restoration work on t mosques.
At the same time he began meeting with
Islamic fundamentalists and reading more
about the teachings of Islam.
Within weeks he had disowned his former
Luke's way of life and to become a
devout Muslim.
At the age of 20 assault,
my entered an arranged marriage with a
devout Syrian woman who was a distant
cousin. Together they immerse
themselves in Islamic fundamentalism,
rejecting Western values and priorities
and condemning it's greatest proponents
of the United States.
When Saudi Arabia,
king five sal was killed
by his derange nephew,
been lardons anti American sentiments.
They were reinforced.
The king's nephew had been educated
in the United States and to become a
complete the westernized bid laws,
and he was thrilled.
In 1979 when a fundamentalist religious
leader known as Ayatollah Ruhollah
Khomeini overthrew the Shah of
Iran who was seen as a puppet.
For the United States.
For the first time,
Islamic fundamentalists so seized a
Muslim country and established and Islamic
state.
Each gave undeniable proof that radical
Islamic forces could prevail over
Western decadence c.
Then towards the end of 1979 the Soviet
Union invaded the largely Muslim nation
of Afghanistan,
Soviet forces.
They were ruthless pouring overwhelming
fire power onto the Afghanistani
resistance.
They could also the president
of Afghanistan and put
their own governments in
place. Middle Eastern Arab nations. They
want understandably alarmed by this.
They were all sympathetic
to the Afghani cause,
but knew that none of them had the
ability to take on the Soviet war machine.
Yet Islamic fundamentalists militants
were determined to do something.
Then I was doing the Soviets and
restoring Islam in its purest sense,
fit that definition of jihad or holy war.
Thousands of young men by Islam rather
than national boundaries traveled to
Afghanistan to risk their
lives for their beliefs.
Among them was a Somac been modern.
Wow.
The savings,
the invasion of Afghanistan.
It was the impetus that took a Sama bin
Ladin out of his comfortable life of
privilege and into his reincarnation.
As a freedom fighter? Yes, yes.
Unlike many others,
he did not unthinkingly grab an AK 47
and rush off to the desert to join the
guerrilla army.
His first stop,
it was in Pakistan where he set up a
recruitment station to bring Muslims from
surrounding Arab nations to
the cause of jihad. It seemed,
became a clear that his
business backgrounds and money,
we're going to be eight huge assets.
He organized to training camps where
the recruits learns the art of Strategic
Warfare Been Mosin.
It knew that the thousands of eager
young men he was gathering together and
needed a support network, so he also
began recruiting doctors, bomb experts,
military strategists and engineers from
all over the Arab wells is families
building backgrounds impelled him to
build the infrastructure that would be
needed to defeat the Soviets.
Many would come to fight sooner.
It found themselves digging trenches,
paving roads and it's
building hospitals and depots.
During the 1980s binladin was instrumental
in bringing together in Afghanistan
Nan's nearby areas of Pakistan,
more than 25,000 Muslim fighters from at
least 35 countries around them as live
well's. Yet support also came
from the most unlikely places.
The United States.
The U S was fixated on stopping Soviet
expansion and so we're willing to support
Islamic efforts to remove the communist
invaders from Afghanistan despite their
hatred of the United States.
That jihadists,
they gladly accepted they're
backing after all. It meant money,
weapons and suppliers.
Still they made sure that America
state well clear of their operations.
One Islamic intelligence officer noted
that no American instructor was ever
involved in giving training on any kinds
of weapon or equipment to the merger
has been or how you
fight it's been laws on.
It was instrumental in securing it from
the United States. Stingers, which way?
Heat seeking ground to air missiles
with the ability to bring down a Soviet
fighter plane with the aid of American
Stinger's been lardons men could bring
down at least 270 aircraft through their
fixation on defeating the Soviet spy,
whatever means necessary.
Vus.
They were creating a monster as
well as bringing money, resources,
and organizational skills or the
jihadist cause they didn't. Martin,
he fought alongside his fellow jihadists.
One of his trips recalls he was a hero
to us because he was on the front line
always moving ahead of everybody else.
He not only gave us money,
but he also gave us himself.
He came down from his palace to live
with the Afghan peasants and the Arab
fighters he cooked with them, ate
with them, dug trenches with them.
That was bin Ladin this way.
Ben Loves him. He was not
afraid of death, can fence.
There was a special place in the hereafter
for those who participated in Jihad.
Hey often stated that one day of fighting
in Afghanistan was like a thousand
days of praying and an ordinary mosque.
As a result,
he was more than willing to
become a martyr for the cause.
In 1989 after a painful decade, the
Soviets finally withdrew from Afghanistan.
Osama bin Ladin Return Saudi Arabia
with the reputation of jihadist heroic.
He was hugely popular among the common
people and the ruling families or
friendship with him as a way to quell a
criticism from Islamic fundamentalists
who saw them as two
western been laws and well,
he milked his hero status for
absolutely everything it was worth.
He spoke a mosques and other places often
drawing large crowds of young men who
were inspired to help create an
Islamic fundamentalist world.
His speeches filled with venom against
the United States were often tapes with
over a million copies circulating
around the Muslim world display.
Returning to the rich
embrace of his family.
The summit did not avail himself of the
lavish lifestyle that was available to
him.
He moved into a modest apartment with
his wife and children and did his best to
live according to the strict
teachings of Islam and yes,
there was a fire still smoldering
inside of him that far.
It was inflamed in 1990 when Iraqi leader,
Saddam Hussein invaded the neighboring
nation of Kuwait with Saudi Arabia
looking to be his next target panic.
It rose in Saudi Arabia. Well been,
wasn't he stepped up? It's,
he offered his assistance.
His experience in Afghanistan had allowed
him to map out a battle strategy that
would be able to save his country.
He was determined to that any Iraqi
aggression be mass by Muslim forces alone.
It's cool on the West for help would be
he argued contrary to Islamic teaching
and demoralizing to the nation bin.
Ladin warns the Saudi government that
assistance from the u s would mean that
Islamic fundamentalists
would withdraw support,
but Saudi Arabia as minister of Defense,
Prince Sultan knew that even been lardons
forces could not defend this country
from the air,
naval and chemical attacks as well as
biological weapons that Saddam Hussein,
how did this disposal on one occasion
been lots and even burst into the
principal's office and yells, there
is no need for American troops. Yes,
we're in the prince asked him how he
could save the people from an hierarchy,
chemical weapon attack. You could only
reply. We will defeat them with our faith.
The Saudi government is rather and
surprising and he did turn to the United
States for help. The results was the Gulf
War. The US led western assault on Iraq.
Saddam was pushed back until negate it.
However,
the outrage of bin Ladin is
fundamentalist followers.
US military forces remained in the
region in case the dog made any further
aggressive moves.
The House of Saudi he would not long
before seen association with Bin Ladin as
an asset.
I've got nervous at a Samas hero status
and huge popularity they wanted to to
restrain him from making negative public
comments about their reliance on the
west,
threatening to remove the lucrative public
contracts that had made his family so
wealthy.
Okay.
The relationship between
[inaudible] and the house of Saudi,
it quickly deteriorated to the point
that in 1991 but he was expelled from the
country. Three years later,
his citizenship was revoked.
He fled to sit down with
his immediate family,
which now included three
wives and 15 children.
They moved into a brick and stucco home
in Khartoum where he lived a simple and
deeply religious life in Sudan,
been mods and quickly found
support for his ideology,
which was fiercely opposed to
any collaboration with the West.
His goal was to overthrow regimes that
were friendly to the u s and establish in
that place true Islamic states.
The first step towards that end would
be to strike at a u s targets throughout
the world.
By doing so,
it was believed that the United States
would be forced to withdraw from the
Middle East.
Even the governments that had been
propped up or by could easily be toppled.
The nucleus of the terrorist organization
that would bring about these changes
was a group that bin Ladin helps
develop and as you might know it,
it was called al Qaida
from their base in Sudan.
Experienced al Qaeda leaders were sent
to various parts of the world where there
were large Muslim populations.
Their mission was to incite and Islamic
revolution and carry out acts of
terrorism and his first year in Sudan,
they love him.
He became a disciple of
Hassan Abdallah to Robbie,
the Islamic spiritual leader of Sudan.
Wasy Robbie helps a sama to
deepen his spiritual development,
been Larson in turn built up to
Robbie's jihadist group Greek,
the popular international
organization or P I own.
He also builds connections with various
international finance institutions to
channel money towards his
growing terror networks.
At the same time he could
smuggle terrorists into the
United States by arranging
for them to be employees of companies
that were owned by wealthy pro Islamic
Middle East and businessmen.
Meanwhile,
Mincey dawn been laws and established a
building company known as the owl Hirafu
construction developments limited.
Its sole purpose was to
build an infrastructure in
Sudan to move the equipment,
vehicles and weaponry needed
to expedite terrorist acts
by the mid 1990s bit laws in an
established a worldwide reputation as a
revolutionary with thousands of young
jihadists idolizing him and dreaming of
being just like him.
The first bombing attack that was credited
to been large and was the December
29th, 1992 attack on two
hotels in Arden, Yemen.
Both hotels were frequented by US
military personnel in the area.
Three people were killed and five
more were wounded in the attack.
This was part of a concerted efforts
to oust the Americans from the Horn of
Africa and assert fundamentalist
Islam power in the region.
The focus of the action was in Somalia
where bin Laden organized fierce fighting
against US forces who were
there for humanitarian purposes,
been laws and counted the withdrawal of
US troops from Mogadishu as among his
most significant victories against the u
s then following his actions in Somalia
Been Ladin turned his attention to
Europe is first step was to bolster the
Islamic fundamentalist
movement in the Balkins.
Before setting his sights on Western
Europe and the United States Muslim
communities in these places,
wet saturated with pro Islamic
anti western propaganda
been laws in also relied
heavily on email and the
Internet to get the word out.
In 1995 Alica eater turned its attention
back to the Middle Eastern nations,
but if the leaved where roadblocks
to the establishment of Islamic
fundamentalist regimes
throughout the Muslim world,
but London saw Egypt and Saudi Arabia as
the two biggest obstacles to his course
in Saudi Arabia, he became obsessed
with overthrowing the house of salt.
In November of 1995 he orchestrated
the bombing of a u s military training
center in Riyadh killing seven people,
thousands of south.
They were outraged at the attack,
convinced the bin. Ladin was behind it.
A few days after the attack
for mercenaries from Yemen
opens fire with Ak 40
sevens outside of his residence in Sudan,
bin Laden's bodyguards
returns firing within minutes.
Three of the assailants and two bodyguards
with debt from that day on some of
the bin Laden's House and street
were transformed into an armed camp.
It wasn't just the house of
salad that we're offering though.
In 1996 a US special forces operation was
launched to capture bin Laden with the
aid of American friendly Muslim nations.
From then on,
he refused to venture out of C.
Dot.
But then both Saudi Arabia and the u s
turned up the screws threatening economic
sanctions on the Sudan unless
they handed the nodding over.
He was quickly asked to leave and he
and his wife and children edit for
Afghanistan in May of 1996
safely ensconced in Afghanistan.
[inaudible] now fully embraced the role
of international leader of the Islamic
extremist movements just stay alive
though me just surround himself with many
body guards.
He established a three room operations
space in a cave that had been carved out
to the side of a mountain that was
equipped with basic furnishings,
is only connections to the outside
world where it's satellite phone and two
laptops.
Then in 1998 been lots turn internists,
destructive attention back to Africa.
It's plan was the bomb two US embassies
in different African countries would
always the seventh simultaneous attacks
in Kenya and Tanzania kills hundreds of
people.
Although he denied responsibility.
The international
community where unanimous,
that's bin Ladin was behind the attacks.
As a result of the u s stepped up its
attempts to take him out with an air
strike on October the 20th known as
Operation Infinite reach. It destroyed it.
Three terrorist training camps in
the Afghani mountains, but bin Ladin,
he remained at large.
A year later, he was connected
to an attack on the u s
Navy destroyer, USS Cole.
There should that stop to refuel in the
port of od in Yemen when the terrorists
blasted this killing 17 sailors less than
a month after that two planes smashed
into the twin towers of
the World Trade Center.
In New York city striking a devastating
blow with the very symbol of American
business and achievement.
Within moments,
it had been transformed into a full
blown war zone. About 45 minutes later,
the terror struck again a high drag
down our liner that it departed from
Virginia with spear headed
into the Pentagon, the
nation's military headquarters,
the horrific,
shocking attack.
The deadliest since Pearl Harbor was a
major wake up call for the United States,
or $25 million reward was offered for
bin Laden and anti terrorist task forces
were set up despite a full on
effort to bring him to justice.
Bin Laden was able to remain at large
plotting further attacks for another
decade.
Sometime in the mid two thousands he
slipped into Pakistan for a while and he
stayed in rural mountain villages
protected by local tribal leaders.
He then moved to the bottom bad
compounds with three of his wives.
He now at five and 13 of his children and
it was that that the Americans finally
got them.
Yeah.
In the early morning hours of May.
The second 2011 about 25 navy seal
commander has descended on the [inaudible]
bad compounds.
They quickly breached the 18 foot walls
and then storms of the house using
explosives to gain entry
to men encountered on the
first floor were killed and
then the commandos rushed upstairs
where they identified and kill has been
Larson.
He was shot in the chest and the forehead.
One of his wives was also shot in the leg.
When she lunged at a seal to
make sure they got their man.
One of the seals took a photo and then
quickly put it through your facial
recognition software.
The results showed a 95% likelihood that
this was some of in London later DNA
testing,
put it beyond a shadow of a doubt.
The world's number one terrorist
is debt or some of it in London.
He was buried at sea shortly
after the race. Unfortunately,
the terror organization that he created,
it remains to this day,
so I really hope you found that
video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday
loads of other people like this and do
check out some of our stuff from the
archives.
You can find it over there on the right,
so click on some of those great
stuff to watch next. And as always,
thank you for watching.